este mensaje es para el que esté listo
de entender
y les quiero preguntar algo quién de
aquí le ha oído un problema y antes de
que me contesten vamos a definir la
palabra problema en dos la primera
si nos vamos a la etimología de la
palabra que proviene del griego problema
y que en el tumbaburros como dice mi
papá es este conjunto de hechos o
circunstancias que dificultan la
consecución de algún fin y la verdad es
que está muy difícil entonces yo creé mi
propia definición qué problema es igual
a todas estas circunstancias de
aprendizaje
tengo esta idea que la decisión de estar
en este mundo tangible en este plano
material si le quieren llamar así fue
una decisión mía acepto que con la ayuda
de algo mucho más poderoso que yo y mi
conciencia decidí venir aquí a descubrir
lo que el amor significa
son un poco cursi pero si eso es lo que
estoy haciendo buscando la definición
perfecta del amor
acepto que mis papás han sido este
transporte y son maestros de mi
aprendizaje igual que igual a todas las
personas con las que me he rodeado
pero si decidí que yo vine a este mundo
porque yo quise
antes cuando mis papás me regañaban me
acuerdo muchas veces de haberles dicho
cómo es que yo no quería estar aquí
ustedes me tuvieron no echándole la
culpa a ellos pero la realidad es que no
podemos vivir
echando la culpa a los demás
no le voy a seguir echando la culpa a
mis papás por las decisiones que tomo oa
mis amigos por las cosas que no hago me
hago responsable de las cosas que si
hago
y a ver vamos a hacer súper conscientes
que el huir es algo que viene en la
naturaleza del ser humano lo vimos a
todo aquello que nos hace sufrir le
oímos a todo aquello que nos duele
aquello que nos lastima que nos parte
que nos hace entrar en esta catarsis
claro que lo vimos a nadie le gustan los
sufrir o así a alguien le gusta sufrir
yo creo que no entonces pues si vamos a
ser muy conscientes de esto porque yo me
consideraba con una maestría en la huida
que digo maestría yo ya daba así
doctorados de cómo ir hoy a los 19 años
de mi casa
wii de mi familia de mis amigos del
trabajo de la escuela y de enfermedades
súper importantes siendo consciente de
ellas y esto me llevó a estar internado
en hospitales y diferentes clínicas
hasta que en un punto estando conectado
en un hospital con mil medicamentos
el doctor me dijo santi
si lo que quieres es oírle a la vida lo
estás logrando
tienes tres meses de vida
qué fuerte no qué fuerte estar en un
hospital y que el doctor te diga eso
eso me hizo reflexionar muchísimo porque
a mí no me gustaba
que me dijeran que estaba mal a menudo
estaba aceptar que tengo problemas a mí
no me gustaba aceptar y entonces ante
cualquier problema que hacía huir
les voy a hacer otra pregunta en esta
plática les voy a hacer como 80.000
preguntas
pero si tienen una pared a encima que
van a hacer
van a buscar pasar la pared como sea o
van a regresar sé por dónde venían
y muchos me pueden decir santi ya estoy
cansado santiago ya intenté muchas veces
santiago ya de verdad tengo flojera
estoy cansado tengo sueño lo que sea
simplemente me pueden decir
ahorita no joven es muy noche
sí
la verdad es que le subimos a las
relaciones por problema con la pareja
pero también lo vimos a la soledad
porque no sabemos estar o no nos gusta
estar solos le vimos al trabajo por
falta de compromiso
con las responsabilidades pero también
lo vimos al desempleo por tener que
enfrentar el no tengo chamba no le vimos
a lo que conocemos porque hicimos ahí es
que es súper repetitivo
pero también lo vimos a lo que no
conocemos por salir de esta zona de
confort
se los voy a intentar hacer un poco más
fácil con mario bros me fascina mario
bros la verdad es que sí y en este caso
yo voy a hacer mario bueno no voy a
hacer luigi porque el verde no está más
entonces va a hacerlo allí y cada
problema va a ser un aprendizaje
yo no puedo pasar de aprendizaje
hasta que no termine lo que tengo que
aprender yo no puedo pasar de nivel
cuánto tiempo va a tardar
ocurrirá tantas veces como sea necesario
para que lo logres aprender
y
a ver
porque porque me cuesta tanto trabajo
porque me cuesta tanto tanto miedo
estos problemas
y esta frase la utilizo muchísimo
si no salgo de una relación que me daña
que me lastima que se que me está
afectando es porque le estoy huyendo a
la soledad
y vamos a cambiar la palabra relación y
soledad por problemas y que cada vez los
problemas sean más fuertes y que cada
vez los problemas tengan un reto más en
nuestra vida en cualquier ámbito el
laboral espiritual personal de salud en
el que quieran
va a llegar un momento en que estos
problemas va a ser la muerte de un
familiar
si yo no salgo de la muerte de mi papá
de mi mamá mis hermanos de mi abuela de
mi perrito si yo no salgo y sé que me
está lastimando que me está dañando que
me afecta es porque le estoy huyendo al
aprendizaje
llegó un momento en esta catarsis de
emociones conectado en el hospital en el
qué
un switch se me prendió
y cambie el es que porque tengo que
vivir esto porque santiago a los 20 años
tenía que vivir una situación que casi
lo puso una muerte
para que santiago a los 19 años bueno 20
tuvo que vivir esto para qué
y eso es lo que sigo buscando y está
aquí enfrente de ustedes para esto
para que una de mis palabras les llegue
a uno de ustedes
y nos damos cuenta
qué
tú
estás viviendo el aprendizaje que tienes
que vivir
y si les cambio el tengo por el debo
tú estás viviendo un aprendizaje que
debes entender
una persona super linda una vez me dijo
que problema significa hacia tu lema qué
problema significa que en el momento en
el que llegue se está catarsis de
emoción en esta catarsis de ya no saber
qué hacer para dónde caminar
en ese momento tiene la solución en tus
manos
la verdad es que a cada uno de ustedes
les deseo y con el amor más profundo de
verdad que llega en este punto de
catársis
porque entonces ahí es donde vamos a
empezar a valorar las cosas
y es algo que de verdad se los digo es
con todo el corazón
creo que muchas veces necesitamos de
estas experiencias
para motivarnos a seguir
porque sí
la verdad es que es una lucha contra ti
es una lucha contra lo de afuera es una
lucha contra lo de adentro contra tu
mente contra tu corazón
es una lucha
contra algo que crees no poder
y claro que puedes
no necesitas que un speaker de télex te
diga tú puedes no lo necesitas lo sabes
perfectamente
pero te cuesta creer en ti
te cuesta reflexionar un poquito y estar
en este momento en el que ya no sepas
para dónde ir
ya no sepa si va a ir para adelante si
te vas a tener que regresar para agarrar
más vuelo y tumbar la pared
los maratonistas tienen este famoso
dicho del muro
que el muro es este momento en el que te
empiezan a llegar mensajes de la cabeza
que te dicen sabes que ya no vas a poder
o paras o te vas a lastimar o te vas a
caer o te vas a lo que quieran ya ya no
voy a poder me voy a parar
con todos los maratonistas que he
platicado que creen que me hice
este muro es momentáneo
muchas veces creemos que el problema que
nos tiene en el problema en el que
estamos
y ya no lo vamos a poder pasar
si vas a poder
debes de creer que vas a poder
efectivamente
creo que le está yendo para adelante
para atrás efectivamente quiero que sepa
cada uno de ustedes
que esto no es personal esto no es una
cuestión de sólo a mí me pasa no
les puedo apostar y en estos cortos 23
años les puedo apostar que todos estamos
luchando contra lo
igual y mi aprendizaje es diferente al
tuyo igual y mi situación es totalmente
diferente a la tuya
pero si no tienes chamba
debes de descubrir porque no tienes
chamba
si no tienes novio no había si no estás
casado si estás divorciado si estás si
se te murió tu esposo y es muy difícil
que yo solo diga yo sé y me pueden decir
santiago tú no sabes lo que estoy
viviendo y efectivamente no lo sé pero
no necesitas que yo ni que nadie te diga
que no puedes
lo que puedes no necesitas eso necesitas
creer
que puedes y por ti si tú no quieres
aprender puedes vivir toda tu vida en
esta negación
y yo cuando no conozco
y yo cuando
[Música]
en cierto momento no tengo las cosas
bajo mi control siendo aquí y cuando
tiene el sartén por el mango
absolutamente nadie porque porque
estamos muy cómodos
porque queremos creer
que el ser humano
necesita de otro ser humano para que lo
salve
te quiero dejar
con prácticamente una frase
y te va a ayudar a pasar de nivel en
mario bros ya vas a ser experto en mario
bros y es que
confía en ti
en esa catarsis de emoción
muchas gracias
qué tan excelente noche y bendiciones
para todos
[Aplausos]